so on the same weekend this summer two
movies open Oppenheimer and the Barbie
movie which movie you walking into
ah is that even a question
[Music]
Barbie Barbie Barbie
Oppenheimer Oppenheimer Bobby all the
way definitely Barbie man I'm gonna go
for Barbie Barbie definitely Oppenheimer
I think we're all excited for the Barbie
movie yeah Barbie yeah Barbie I'm going
Oppenheimer at the Chinese Theater
Oppenheimer Oppenheimer of course Barbie
do you want to defend your answer I
don't have to
confidence I like it I'm gonna see
Barbie I'm excited Barbie it's a clean
sweep for Barbie Barbie probably yeah
Barbie I got my tickets for Oppenheimer
in this theater actually it will be
often higher I am a Christopher Nola fan
Barbie all the way yeah Barbie I would
have to say Barbie because I don't know
what the other movie is and all right
because we don't know what Oppenheimer
has received I'm really one with the
nuke the nuke nuke the heart behind her
I'm going with that I'm going nuke nuke
all day we got to see how it started we
got a Hiroshima we hope with all that we
World War II going with that
saying there's a chance that when we
push that button
we destroy the world chances are near
zero we actually have a double feature
plans you're gonna see me doing split
viewings Barbie first and then up and
over here so I'm gonna see Barbie first
and then Oppenheimer next I'm walking
into Barbie at 10 A.M and another
Oppenheimer at 7 p.m that's how you do
it why pick we're thinking Oppenheimer
first and then get some margaritas
afterwards and then Barbie it up you
know I think that's probably the best
case scenario you know when you watch a
scary movie you needed like an upper
afterwards so like make you feel less
terrified it's kind of what we're gonna
do Barbie it works best after Margaritas
the first one has got to be Oppenheimer
just because I could get the depressing
stuff out of the way first oh that was a
downer okay let's go have fun on Barbie
now that I'm being put to the test maybe
I'll go watch the other one she's doing
a double feature I'm gonna finish one
refill my popcorn and go see the second
one it's all about the popcorn the first
one because I'm not seeing Barbie you
refuse to see Barbie why I'm not paying
for it you're not gonna pay to see
Barbie why not doesn't look good you
never had the Barbie Dream House not dog
have anything big planned just a giant
blowout party with all the Barbies and
planned choreography and a bespoke song
you should stop by so cool
I have a soft spot for Christopher Nolan
so I'm ready to go it's gonna be the
best movie of the year first of all I'm
a huge Chris Nolan fan so I've been
waiting for this one I was saying
Oppenheimer like last year like before
Summer started with my friend just
messing around and all of a sudden they
came out with a movie for us so are you
the genius behind the Oppenheimer
movement y'all seen right here what is
that one about is it another uh
historical Christopher Nolan World War
II Epic oh yeah I'd watch that I'm a fan
of Nolan I love his work and I love a
biopic there's something about like
science and the atom bomb so I'm
intrigued by that project I'm in the
front row like row I mean I got my own
seat by myself so I want to see that
whole movie Just explosions like right
in my face
for Barbie
[Laughter]
[Music]
looks insane in the best way it looks so
good it's about time they have it live
since all these cartoons and all these
voiceovers it's good to have actual
people play the characters we grew up
living on Barbie I mean we had the
Barbie townhouse the Barbie camper the
Barbie car we used to dream up all these
scenarios for the Barbies I can't wait
to see what they're going to do with the
Barbie movie I love Greta garwig I love
Margot Robbie I think it's going to be
brilliantly put together the marketing
floor has been fantastic it's got some
really interesting cameos the shoe the
shoe the foot thing intrigues me have
you seen it when she steps out the shoe
and it's like
tiptoes and Ryan Gosling is Ken does
that work and then I guess he's okay so
I'm not about him being Ken I don't
think I like him no I just don't like
his face
you don't like Ryan Gosling's fate
that's a that's a high bar to surpass
Ryan Gosling's face my goodness
blonde hair and stuff I'm not liking it
the guy in it the attracted guy that was
in la la land yeah Ryan Gosling plays
Ken I'll pick that one so you're going
to see Barbie
he has my girl Robbie in it as Barbie no
she might assume I think we know who's
seen Barbie
okay well the guy in The Notebook Ryan
Gosling is playing Ken in the Barbie
movie so that's like perfect casting
right yeah it's sexy so do you think the
Barbie movie might make you cry again
maybe if I say with that it's tougher
[Applause]
Truman needs to know what's next what's
next what that's all for on the street
I'm Mark Ellis reminding you subscribe
right here and comment which movie are
you most excited to see the rest of the
summer season Barbie Oppenheimer we'll
see you next time right here at Rotten
Tomatoes whichever way you go Barbie or
Oppenheimer make sure after you see the
movies you rate and review at Rotten
Tomatoes I'm a Barbie guy in a Barbie
world yeah can we get Mike a Barbie
Dreamhouse he really wants one he's
crying fun me right now Robbie's playing
Barbie does that make you want to go see
it I would like to retract my previous
statement it's already on camera you
said you weren't gonna go see it scratch
that from the tape